where is belarus and what does it have
to do with the conflict between russia
and ukraine
[Music]
belarus borders both ukraine and russia
and was once part of the soviet union in
1991 the country declared independence
and in the decades since belarus's
leader alexander lukashenko has
attempted to remain as independent and
neutral as possible while maintaining a
close relationship with vladimir putin
for example belarus did not recognize
russia's annexation of crimea in 2014
but since a highly controversial and
disputed presidential election in 2020
where lukashenko cracked down hard on
huge national protests against him after
claiming the presidency he's had to rely
much more on his friend in the kremlin
as the west has imposed tough sanctions
against his regime
meanwhile relations between ukraine and
belarus have become strained belarus has
accused ukraine of becoming increasingly
aligned with the west for example by
rejecting the results of the 2020
presidential election
the majority voted for me despite them
seeing me every day everywhere
nearly half of belarus's foreign trade
is with russia and in the last 20 years
the kremlin has lent alexander
lukashenko an estimated 100 billion
dollars and that's picked up in the wake
of those disputed elections where
lukashenko really had nowhere else to
turn so it's no surprise that vladimir
putin is leaning on their support now
[Music]
belarus is key geographically for russia
and to the rest of europe
the sawalki gap a 65 kilometer stretch
of land that makes up the border between
poland and lithuania is also bordered by
belarus and by the russian enclave of
kaliningrad nato knows this is its
weakest point because if russia was to
take control it could cut off the rest
of eastern europe
in response to the conflict nato has
increased the number of troops in the
baltics and poland
[Music]
it was belarus that russian troops used
as a launch pad for their initial
invasion of ukraine after spending
months conducting what they build as
military drills there
has openly offered not only to host
troops but also russia's nuclear weapons
after a referendum to revoke the
country's non-nuclear status
that's worrying because it could allow
russia to target parts of europe with
short-range weapons and is a sign that
belarus is becoming more of a player in
this conflict
in response the u.s has withdrawn its
few remaining embassy workers from the
capital minsk and has threatened they
will impose further sanctions if belarus
continues to aid and abet russian
aggression
so in an increasingly precarious
conflict belarus is a key player